[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Cereal.
The humble breakfast
staple is hardly
something to revolt
over, [BREAKING GLASS]
or so I thought.
Because in September 2015,
a group of protesters
got really mad over
an East London store
that sold the innocuous
breakfast for around $5 to $7,
which to be fair, is a
lot when you consider
it's just a bowl of cereal.
The angry mob hurled
bottles, smashed windows,
and even burned an
effigy of a policeman.
Now the riot wasn't because
the place had run out of, well,
this.
The fight was really about
a much bigger problem--
gentrification.
The protesters are an
anti-gentrification group
called the [BLEEP] Parade.
The group launched their
campaign against the store
because they felt it symbolized
a bigger problem in London,
and, indeed, in many other
metropolises around the world.
Many anti-gentrification
protesters
aren't 100% opposed to
the idea of urban renewal.
But they do have a
problem with what it's
doing to local communities.
Higher rents and
housing prices mean
established
working-class communities
are being forced to move.
The [BLEEP] Parade
have even gone as far
as describing the problem in
London as social cleansing.
And people aren't
necessarily moving in
to replace those who have left.
Urban renewal, gentrification,
whatever you want to call it,
is making properties in cities
like London much more desirable
for foreign investors,
or those who are
wanting to buy a vacation home.
So now, imagine walking
down a street at night,
in one of the most vibrant
cities in the world, only
to find it's eerily quiet.
There are no lights on in the
houses, because, well, nobody's
home.
This is actually happening
in London boroughs
like Camden and Hammersmith.
To paraphrase a popular
British band from the '70s,
pockets of London are
looking like a ghost town.
And the same exact thing
is happening in New York,
Melbourne, and San Francisco.
Ghost towns are an extreme
manifestation of urban renewal,
but it does highlight
the real bone
of contention surrounding the
practice-- loss of community.
Because the essence
of why somewhere
is desirable to live can't be
bought or built. It's true.
Anti-gentrification protesters
should not have used violence
to get their point across.
But there is some
truth when they
say, "We don't want luxury
flats that no one can afford.
We want genuinely
affordable housing.
We want community."
And this might hit home
when, instead of London,
it's echoing through
the streets of what
used to be your neighborhood.
There's another fight
over land development
happening in America,
involving the US Government,
Big Oil, and, believe it
or not, a prairie chicken.
To find out more,
check out this episode.
SPEAKER 2: The energy
industry got upset
because their land
use could be limited.
Conservationists got
upset because they
thought the land use still
wouldn't be limited enough.
And it really only got
crazier from there.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks for
watching, and don't forget
to subscribe to Seeker Stories.
[MUSIC PLAYING]